[Music]
I'm Patrick B your host of weekly and we
are right now in Aspen Colorado we
brought 50 of our friends here to uh
hang out at St reges and uh we've been
snowboarding skiing having a great time
but it's that time of year where
everybody keeps asking about their
business plans and hey take a look at my
business plan and what do you think
about my business plan and for many
years I wrote business plans that did
nothing for me I wrote one time and tell
me if this is typical for you as well we
wrote it one time maybe looked at it a
couple times and that's pretty much it
and then you go back and say next I got
to write another business plan and
another business plan and eventually I
realized most business plans are just
not effective because all people write
down is in numbers and here's what I'm
going to do this year or here's the kind
of things I'm going to buy myself so I
prefer life plans versus business plans
and ever since I started writing life
plans my heart got into into the plan I
was writing I read it differently I
looked at it differently it was more
intentional than a regular business plan
so let me give you an idea about what my
life plan looks like when every year I
write out a new life plan and so
remember I could do a two-hour session
on this I'm going to give you a very
Readers Digest version of it today so
you can kind of get an idea what it
looks like first thing I write down a
lot of times we write down our numbers
and our business goals the first thing I
write down is Patrick things you need to
improve in point number one things you
need to improve in so under that you
write down whatever things you need to
improve in for instance uh maybe you
need to improve in dealing with
difficult personalities because you
don't know how to deal with difficult
people and every time it ends bad you
need to improve in that right uh maybe
you need to handle your finances better
you keep making a lot of money but you
don't have any money in Saving so maybe
you're a bad spender you need to improve
in that maybe you curse a lot you got to
stop cursing maybe it's uh something you
got to work on that's personal to you so
it's things that you personally need to
improve on numbers are not going to come
in place unless if you personally
improve so Point number two to that is
my personal development goals personal
development goals are uh a couple ways I
put it one the number of books I'm going
to read two I suggest you join a book
club I have a book club myself every
month we do we're going to have a new
one in 2015 so joining a book club or uh
uh I study subjects is what I do every
year I take a couple subjects and I
study it which means I read six books on
one subject cuz I want to know know
about how to you know get my health
better or how to get my finances better
or how to communicate better negotiate
better whatever it is study subjects
with personal development my
associations I write down my
associations new mentors people in your
life uh personal development is a very
very important thing uh that's number
two in my plans then number three goes
to affirmations every year um I suggest
creating 50% of your affirmations being
new affirmations sometime people read
the same old affirmations every single
year I create new affirmations every
single year I'll use my same steady ones
that stay every year because that's my
values and principles that's who I am
that's what I stand for those are some
things that are not going to change 10
20 30 years from now but every year new
affirmations are tied to areas I want to
improve in as a person so those
affirmations constantly remind me to
improve in those specific areas that is
combined with personal development then
after my affirmations it goes to family
uh what I need to improve on with my
family that means how can I become a
better father so I'll read books on how
to raise boys I'll read books on
Parental capacity what do I need to do
to become a better father or what do you
need to do to become a better mother son
uh any of those things that's family so
what are some family goals that we write
down then what are some ways I can
improve in my family so my wife and I
will talk talk about it my kids will
talk about it I'll talk about it my
father I'll talk about it my family next
one is Faith uh Faith to me is very
important role I am where I am because
of my faith I'm a byproduct of it you
know it's it's it's uh it's changed my
life I've uh uh become who I am because
I've practiced my faith and I've been
reminded with mentors to challenge me to
practice my faith uh I am a Christian is
what I am but uh whatever Faith you are
I want to challenge you to practice your
faith I see a lot of time people say
whatever Faith they are but they rarely
practice their faith it's very very
important for you to practice your faith
so having a plan in place what is your
goal for your faith it could be reading
the Bible it could be reading certain
books maybe least Strobel you know CS
Lewis it could be Max locado whatever it
is that you're studying some things that
you want to find out about a certain
Faith or maybe you lost yourself like I
was 10 years ago so you got to study a
little bit of everything to get clarity
but you got to have a goal with your
faith and then areas to improve on with
your faith maybe it's praying three
times a day maybe it's praying at nights
that's Faith goals then it's uh friend
goals uh I have goals with friends so I
write down every year who are the 10
people I spend the most time with and I
ask myself which of these friends have
uh uh friends who are totally supporting
me what I'm doing with my life and they
elevate me and they challenge me and
they they're good with my wife and
they're good with my family and you know
we understand each other we have common
values and principles and you know in
life I did an episode that one prior to
this that I said four the hardest things
to find one of the ones is a great
friend so you make a list of friends and
then uh from there what are your goals
with friend what are you looking for in
a friend well maybe you're married now
you want to associate yourself more with
married couples maybe you have kids now
you want to associate yourself with
other couples who are good mothers and
fathers that you can learn from and your
spouse can learn from as well and that
becomes your Association but you need to
have a I also have a plan for friends
what is a good friend um to you and what
does that look like and how do you
improve and choosing friends sometimes
the skill of choosing friends is a skill
set that you got to improve in and
sometimes you got to realize some
friends just don't support you some
friends you around them they don't make
you feel good about yourself they don't
make you feel that that you want to
they're always negative and gossiping
and do you really want that in your life
you got to make that choice so that's uh
on the friend list then it's a health
list uh business plan means nothing if
your stamina is not good business plan
will not do anything if you want to come
home early cuz you're tired a business
plan with all the numbers you write them
won't do nothing for you if you've
gained 30 pounds in 2014 and you don't
feel good and you wake up later and you
sleep earlier and you feel lethargic and
you don't feel good about yourself so
health is an extremely important part of
a business plan that's why I call it a
life plan so health I'm going to drop
soda goals and what to improve in my
goal is to lose 20 pounds my goal is to
be 15% body fat my goal is to whatever
it may be so I'm going to drop bread
after 6:00 I'm going to drop ice cream
I'm going to drop this how can I improve
that area of my health I need to get a
personal trainer I'm not good working
out by myself so maybe I need to find
somebody me and my wife are going to go
walk every night I feel like I got to
get my spouse to also work out so maybe
we can create a workout routine together
maybe we can get the family to work out
cuz our kids are not working out and
they're getting out of shape and we're
out of shape we're not leading by
example we need to collectively go and
do something work you on maybe a family
hike those are some traditions that you
can create on the health side then
business goals you write down your
business goals and business goals you go
back and you look at your 2014 goals and
look at what percentage of your numbers
in your business goals you actually hit
you don't write a business plan to no go
not go back and look at it so you take
that a business plan and you highlight
green I hit this I hit this I didn't hit
this I didn't hit this go why didn't I
hit this goal why is this one so far off
why am I so far on this one I really hit
this one good but why did I achieve this
goal so well so then based on that you
put your next business goals for 2015 or
2016 Whatever Whenever you watch this
video then you write down your goals for
specific areas that you need to to hit
in your business measurable numbers than
areas you need to improve in in your
business you know your business on where
you need to improve on then from there
goes into personal
wealth sometimes I meet a lot of people
that make a lot of money and I ask them
how much money they have in savings they
have nothing in savings I wonder how do
you not have money in savings bad
spender you don't have a personal wealth
plan it's just a personal income plan
and then I meet people who don't have a
lot of money in savings but also have a
bad income so then you need to find an
opportunity or become an entrepreneur so
but you need to have a person personal
wealth plan yourself America is not
getting any cheaper to live in America
nowadays things are going to get more
expensive inflation is going to get more
expensive we have $80 trillion of unpaid
debt that money is going to come from
taxpayers and US creating jobs so what
can you do to position your family
better in creating your wealth so
personal wealth goals areas to improve
in I need to become a I need to increase
my business Acumen I need to become
better at understanding business I need
to become better at understanding
Investments Insurance estate planning
whatever that may be then it's selfish
goals and I'm very big on selfish goals
selfish goals I've been using for many
many years 10 years I remember one time
I said if I hit a certain number of
savings and uh I hit that number I want
to buy myself a Harley-Davidson Night
Rod special before I even know how to
ride a motorcycle a friend of mine Jim
uh God bless his soul he rode my bike
back to the office and that night at
11:00 I learned how to ride a motorcycle
and was a Night Rod special I love the
bike uh but I've had many selfish goals
over the years one of my selfish goals
the first one was if I hit a certain
income level was the first time I made
six figures New Year's I want to be in
New York celebrating the ball dropping
in New York at a beautiful hotel right
in front of the ball angle shopping
$5,000 buying clothes that was one of my
goals it's a selfish goal it drove me to
want to do some things cuz I like
clothes for you could be a car it could
be jewelry it could be a vacation with
your spouse and it's very very important
to get your life Life Plan involved with
your spouse so your selfish goals need
to be triggered based on a number you
hit you can't just put a selfish goal
and you give it to yourself or the heck
of it there's got to be a trigger to it
so if I hit this I get this if I do this
I get that if I hit this I get this so
you feel more com comfortable when you
buy it when you're driving it when
you're living in it when you're wearing
it because you know you fought hard to
get it the feeling of earning is in what
you wear and in what you own and the
last one is life goals uh which is
purpose goals uh these could be
political goals you have these could be
charity goals charitable goals that you
have this could be a legacy goal for
your family that you have uh and this is
something that every year will be in
your business plan in your life plan and
it could be something that you write uh
you want to write a book or you want to
uh uh create a family CR it could be
some of those things that are bigger
Legacy type of life goals that stays in
your life plan every single year over
and over and over and over again and
this is the reason why I'm not a fan of
a business plan this life plan gets me
excited and I think it'll get you
excited as well but once you write a
Life Plan it's important to post it all
over the place I suggest creating a
recording if you want to take it to a
whole another level reading it out loud
and putting it in your iPhone when
you're listening to it every single day
to be reminded about your life goal at
night before you go to sleep and if you
can put it somewhere where even your
family hears it even better because then
everybody's buying into the goal
together for instance if we hit this
we're going to go to Hawaii together
we're going to go to Italy together kids
are getting a we're going to go to
Disney World together then the kids are
excited about you working harder because
everyone's fighting for the same life
plan the life goals that we're putting
together so my challenge to you rip
apart that business plan you've written
sit down and watch this video again and
write out your life plan and if you have
family and friends and other co-workers
with you that need to watch this video
as well to write out their life plan
share this video with them if you got
any questions comment on the bottom if
not thanks for watching this
[Music]
video